hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well it is very short
dialogue the ion and Socrates and the
interlocutor after whom the dialogue is
named ion wraps out an interpreter of
Homer's poetry they engage in a
discussion about the nature of poetry
and about what's going on when the poet
or the Raps ode is engaging in
composition or interpretation Socrates
is and Plato's doing this is steering
ion towards what we can call a theory of
divine inspiration or enthusiasm or
possession and ion is just sort of going
along for the ride he's not really sure
what happens with him when he's
interpreting and he seems to find that
that what Socrates puts forward as an
explanation that's a good portion of his
experience but but not all of it
Socrates and I'm doing another core
concept video on this so I'm not going
to elaborate this socrates is engaged in
trying to see whether ion actually does
what he does from art or skill or
knowledge in Greek a piston may or
techne does he
a kind of craft by which he is able to
judge between the better and the worse
of other people in that craft not just
Homer does he actually have knowledge
pertaining to the things that are that
are being discussed in the poetry that
he's interpreting or is something else
going on and as it turns out there's a
lot of discussion of this it turns out
that according to Plato the poet does
not really possess knowledge so how is
the poet and when we think poet what we
ought to think is cultural innovator
cultural creator somebody who is in the
Greek terms not just creating poetry in
the sense of nice rhyming verses but
drama literature in our time the poet's
would include not only the writers but
also the filmmakers TV producers and
writers and I suppose musicians as well
since they they write their own lyrics
and they they put those and that so
imagine all of that involved in this
this Greek discussion so the question is
they're able to have some effects
they're able to speak or to produce
cultural artifacts that are very moving
that that audience is actually like that
audiences feel tell them something that
communicate a certain kind of truth and
how are they doing that if they're not
doing that by knowledge then what are
the other possible alternatives maybe
they're just lucky that's not one that
that Socrates considers in this yeah and
again it helps to know a little bit
about the ancient Greek context poetry
at least some of the poetry was carried
out in relation to religious rituals and
festivals particularly comedy and
tragedy which were written originally as
poetry Homer
and he'll see it and some of these older
poets are writing about the gods so
they're already connected with what you
could call theology in general for the
Greeks that is discourse about God or
the gods and even the lyric poetry you
know we have hymns to two particular
deities that were used probably
liturgically in some cases what's going
on with that well you know one thing
that that's sort of suggested by all
this connection with the divine is the
poet is actually inspired by something
divine so if they're not using strictly
human capacities that are acquired by
reason and by practice and training of
art or skill or science or knowledge
then they're using something that's
above that and it would make sense then
why a poet can only speak about certain
things or why some poets only produce
one good piece of poetry other poets you
know produced many good pieces of poetry
but they they worked with in this genre
or that job or that genre and for the
Greeks it wasn't just a matter of genre
it was also a matter of the very meter
of the poetry that you were writing so
the kind of the kind of meter that
you're using what I mean by that is how
the line goes think about rap music and
how rap music uses meter the way that
the lines go is determined by the kind
of poetry that you're doing so epic
poetry is different than lyric poetry is
different than tragedy is different than
comedy not only because of the subject
matter but because of the very way in
which the words are arranged together so
why is it that some poets are you know
able to do this but not this why is it
that some poets can treat certain themes
but not others why is it that
interpreters instead of being able to
interpret the entire
corpus of Greek poetry and you know say
whether somebody is speaking well or
speaking poorly not only in Homer but in
our coloca or in Solon or you know pick
whoever you like
Hesiod why are why is somebody like I am
only able to interpret Homer
successfully well if it's a matter of
divine inspiration that would make sense
and the the Socrates uses a metaphor to
explain this he talks about magnets and
as you all know because you have
experimented with magnets probably when
you were kids if you have a magnet and
then you have a piece of iron or steel I
think there's one other element that is
magnetic as well and you click the
magnet to the piece of steel the
magnetism is transferred in part
although more weakly to the piece of
steel a piece of iron and that can pick
up another one now imagine you have a
magnet and you have rings iron rings and
you click one here and now you click
another one here and now you click
another one here the Rings can be
suspended depending on the power of the
magnet pretty far down and they're not
linked together what's holding them
together is the power of the magnet I
suppose although Plato doesn't actually
go into this you could think of a
contrary metaphor if you actually
possessed knowledge it would be like
having a ring and then another ring
through that ring which is linked and
then another ring through that ring
which is late and you would have
knowledge you know as a steady chain
going all the way down provided each
member of the chain linked itself to the
one before in the way that the one
before had linked itself to the one
prior to that the right way in this case
you don't have that you have this magnet
and you have all of these rings attached
to to that but they're only attached by
magnetic force take the magnet away and
suddenly they all fall apart so it's
very different than than what Plato is
calling knowledge another thing that he
focuses on
in this very brief discussion and ion is
really attuned to this is the fact that
we share not just knowledge
well not knowledge we we share opinion
or we share appearances or we share
images through poetry but we also share
something even more important which is
emotion so I'll just reading a few
instances he has this great example he
says suppose you're reciting epic poetry
and thrill the spectators most deeply or
chanting say the story of Odysseus as he
leaped up on the diets unmasked himself
to the suitors and poured the arrows out
before his feet when you chant these are
you in your senses or are you carried
out of yourself and does not your soul
in such an ecstasy conceived itself to
be engaged in the actions you relate
whether there is the cour Troy and ayan
says yeah that's exactly what happens
Socrates whenever I say it whenever I
recite a tale of pity I feel pity when I
recite a tale of sadness I feel sadness
when I recite a tale in which you know
in this case the discus is actually
taking names and kicking ass so to speak
right it's at the end of the the Odyssey
not completely at the end but the end
for the suitors because what does
Odysseus doing he's in his own house
where these guys have been trying to
date his wife you know a whole bunch of
them and acting like a bunch of fools
for three years and he unmasks himself
now they know who he is
we're in this guy's house he's got a
whole set of arrows he's got a bow
that's that he's the only guy who can
actually draw it back because it's so so
powerful and now he just starts laying
arrows into these guys and you feel a
sense of emotion when that's that's
going on just you know talking about it
right okay I actually feel a kind of
sense of elation a bit and speaking
about it but that's because I I know
that that poetry and I know that scene
and also because Homer has depicted the
character of Odysseus so well and tied
it in with a plot and all these these
sorts of things Plato would say and
I on would say that's what what is being
transmitted at that point is emotion and
this emotion is ecstatic it's taking our
it's taking us out of ourselves into the
image the time the plot the situation
that is being depicted so Socrates will
say yeah it's kind of weird I mean think
about it you go to the tragedy and you
see these people crying their eyes out
even though nothing bad is happening to
them you see them scared you know even
though nobody is attacking them or
despoiling them how is it that they
share those emotions well again that
gets us to this this metaphor and I
don't have rings here but but this is
the the way in which it works according
to Socrates and I ancestral sense so
it's a case of the divine entering into
possession of the human overflowing
saturating to use late theologians term
the everyday world of the human and in
transforming it in some ways so we
started with the gods or the muses
Socrates can shift back and forth and
they did inspire the poet and depending
on which he says you know depending on
which music is the poet is inspired
differently different gods inspire
different kinds of poetic reflections or
reverberations or however you want to
conceive it and so the poet then writes
communicates speaks is sort of a
mouthpiece of the God not in the same
way that a soothsayer or a seer or
somebody like that in ancient Greece
would or a prophet if you think about
that in the Old Testament term but the
poet is being inspired by by the gods
he's being sort of taken out of himself
showing things made to feel things and
then he tries to put that down in in
verse and in one way or another
once you've got poetry
now you can have interpreters and Homer
did indeed have many interpreters by the
time that Plato is writing and they
would compete against each other for who
could be the best interpreter and part
of that meant being able to recite the
poetry really well and that does take
something I mean if you've ever tried to
you know sing a song that you already
know you know that if you can't relate
to the song it's hard to sing it well
likewise with with poetry if you read
poetry and it's just a bunch of words to
you even if you memorize the verses it's
not really going to come across it works
out with music too you practice a piece
and if you can't find something in that
piece that you latch on to you can't
interpret it very well and it comes
across being very mechanical but when
you are actually an interpreter who is
able to receive the flow of inspiration
or enthusiasm from the poet who got it
from the God then you're able to
continue that process you are the next
link in that chain and then you can
transfer that to the audience now
Socrates doesn't talk about the need for
the audience to be cultivated in any way
that would be an interesting wrinkle to
add to this he seems to just think that
the audience look at the if the
interpreter is doing his job well the
audience is going to get it they're
going to respond they're going to feel
those emotions they're gonna see those
images they're gonna be transported of
themselves back into ancient you know
Greece or ill if the contour try ethical
by the way it's part of Greece I know
that so don't put a comment saying that
but the audience then is also in a
certain way participating in the Divine
through the interpreter through the poet
ultimately going back to the God or the
muse who inspire them so that's what
Plato at least in the ion represents
poetry as doing not only poetry
but it's successful interpretation so
there's a lot of questions left open
here does this match up with everything
else that Plato says about poetry
throughout the rest of his corpus
perhaps not but we don't need to worry
about that here it's enough to
understand if you want to take away one
thing from this remember that metaphor
of the Rings the magnet the next ring is
the poet the next ring is the
interpreter and the next ring is the
audience all of them suspended by the
magnetic force the divine force coming
through them and flowing into them
allowing there to be a continuity there